As the nation
closes in on the first contest of 2020
for one of Donald Trump's
most vocal
Republican critics
is offering
a very chilling new assessment
of what his second presidency
would actually look like
if if he's reelected.
Here's CNN's Christine Romans.
A fresh warning from a leading critic
of Donald Trump
about the danger
posed by the former president
to American democracy.
A vote for Donald Trump
may mean the last election
that you ever get to vote in.
Those comments
come as Trump attempts
to turn the tables on such warnings.
Joe Biden is not the defender
of American democracy.
The former president,
who is facing
felony charges over his attempts
to overturn the 2020
election, claiming
President Joe
Biden is the real risk to the country.
Joe Biden is the destroyer here
of American democracy.
It's him and his people.
They're the records
of the American dream.
A spokesman for the Biden
campaign calling
Trump's comments a, quote,
desperate attempt at distraction.
Trump's attacks
come as Biden and his allies
frame the 2024 election
as a choice
between democracy
and authoritarianism,
signaling how both candidates
are increasingly focused
on a potential general election rematch.
Even as the first votes
in the Republican
nominating contest
won't be cast for another six weeks,
we have to stand up for American values
embedded in the Constitution,
the Declaration of Independence,
because we know
that Mike Ashley is already proven
they won't
wait to stand up
for our constitutional institutions
and legacy
because MAGA
statements have made it clear
they're not going to.
In his latest bid for the White House,
Trump has continued to rail
against democratic institutions
and make false claims
about the 2020 election.
They rigged
the presidential election in 2020,
and we're not going to allow them
to rig the presidential election in 2024.
He also suggested the U.S.
Constitution should be terminated
in a social media post,
and the former president
has outlined
plans to dramatically reshape
the federal government,
including a pledge
to use the Justice Department
to target political opponents.
I mean, if somebody
if I happen to be president
and I see somebody who's doing well
and beating me
very badly,
I say go down and indict them.
Mostly that would be
you know, they would be out of business.
They'd be out.
They'd be out of the election.
Donald Trump has also said that
if reelected to a second term,
that he would make it easier
to fire civil servants
to replace them with a loyalist
as well as he would expand
his hardline immigration policies.
And he has called
for mass deportation now.
This messaging
and this outline of what
a second term would look like
is clearly resonating with some people.
We are just about six weeks away
from the Iowa caucuses
and he is still leading
all of his Republican rivals
by a hefty margin in those polls.
And it's not just in Iowa.
He's also leading them nationally as well
Wolf. Kristen Holmes reporting for us.
Thank you very much. Let's get some more.
All of this.
Joining us now, CNN's Kaitlan Collins,
a veteran of covering covering the Trump
White House.
Caitlyn, this is not the first time
we've seen Trump
try to turn the tables on his opponents.
But is this a winning idea for him?
Well, it's a tactic that he always uses.
I mean, remember, in the 2016
campaign lit up
after the Access Hollywood tape came out,
and then at the next debate, he brought
Bill Clinton's
accusers to the pre debate,
had kind of teased this idea
that he might be dropping out
and then brought them.
He often accuses people
of what they accused him of doing.
And this is the argument
that President Biden has been making long
before he was even in the White House.
He believes it's actually helped.
What helped drive him into
the White House is making this argument
about democracy.
It's what President
Biden plans to use
as he is trying to seek
a second term here.
And I think when Trump
is accusing Biden of this, I mean, we can
it's not even based on,
you know, just Trump's words.
Look at his actions we all witnessed
as he tried
to overturn the election results in 2020.
And it was very clear.
And so
you don't even really have to look deep
into what his advisers are saying
or his allies.
You can see it in his own actions
that he was the one who actually tried
to subvert democracy.
But it is something
that they are trying to use.
I mean, they're even going
to the great lengths
of printing out these signs
that say Biden attacks
democracy, pushing it out
because they want to try
to neutralize the argument that they know
is going to be the chief
one made by President
Biden on the campaign trail.
Can anything really rein in Trump
if there is a second term?
I don't think so.
I think this is something
that you're hearing from people
who are working with Trump
now, saying
that it's a positive thing,
that he won't be stymied by people
working against his agenda.
But you hear from a lot of people
who worked for him in 2020
or is up to 2020 inside the White House
who have real concerns about this.
I mean, people like John
Kelly has spoken out about it,
people like Bill Barr,
the former attorney general.
And they're concerned.
And what you hear from other people
is that
Trump's not going to hire
anyone who disagrees with him
this time around.
He's only going to hire
people who
not only don't push back on him,
but work to carry out his wishes.
And that was often
a great frustration of his.
His first few years in office
was because
he tried to get something done
and then they would say, that's illegal.
It's not doable.
You don't have the authority to do that.
And he would push back.
They're going to be looking to people
who don't do that.
And there's a real concern
that there would impede
the checks and balances on him
if he is reelected,
because he doesn't have to worry
about being reelected again,
which is often something that advisers
would try to use previously
to try to say, well,
if you do this, it's
going to hurt your reelection.
And he's not going to have
the John Kelly's and the bill bars
and those people working for him.
They've made very clear
that's not who they're going to hire.
And as Liz Cheney
warned today, House Republicans
basically do anything that Trump wants.
That's not going to be an effective check
either on Capitol Hill.
And he's still way,
way ahead in all the polls.
See what happens.
All right, Caitlin,
thank you very, very much.
This important note to our viewers.
We will see Kaitlan later tonight, 9 p.m.
Eastern for the source.
Let's bring in more political experts
right now to break all of this down.
And Gloria Borger,
Liz Cheney says the U.S.
is sleepwalking
into dictatorship, her words.
Is there any reason to think
Republican voters, though, are listening?
Well, there's one
group of Republican voters
that are not listening,
and those are the Republican voters
who are dedicated to Donald Trump
and stick with him
through thick and thin.
And the ones who have
who have gone to him
since he's been indicted.
But I think there are Republicans
who are on the
fence who might listen to a Liz Cheney.
But I think it's incumbent
upon Democrats
to continue
to bring the receipts
about the things
that the Donald Trump is saying,
you know, talking
about using the Justice Department
for personal retribution,
how he would hollow out the government
with loyalists, mass deportations.
And I think that those issues
have not been talked about a lot.
And maybe a lot of people
aren't listening.
But it's incumbent
upon Democrats to start
getting the public to focus on
what kind of government
there would be in a second
Donald Trump term
with advisers
who are loyal to him and no one else.
And it would be Donald Trump Unchained.
You know, there would be no guardrails.
Yeah, it's amazing
when you think about it.
Scott Jennings,
let me get your reaction
to more of what Liz Cheney said
earlier today in an interview.
Listen to this.
A vote for Donald Trump
may mean the last election
that you ever get to vote in.
And again, I don't say that lightly.
And I think it's heartbreaking that
that's where we are.
But people have to recognize that
a vote
for Donald Trump
is a vote against the Constitution.
So, Scott, how do you respond?
Can you vote for both
Trump and the Constitution?
Well,
I think that statement is hyperbolic.
Personally, I guess I have more faith
in our constitutional order
and our institutions
in our other political leaders.
I know we obviously had a challenge
to that system in 2020.
And, you know,
we all saw it unfold
live on our televisions.
But the system held
and I actually think the American people
are going to deliver
a very clear verdict
in the next election.
I know it's you know,
we're talking about it's
going to be close in a handful of states
and here and there.
But I think we're going to clearly see
where the American people want to go.
I don't know who's going to win, but I.
I have more faith
in our constitutional order
and our institutions than perhaps
Representative Cheney, who I
respect greatly is
is espousing right now.
Van Jones is with us as well.
Van, The New York Times writes about this
and writes
about what could happen
in a second Trump administration.
Let me read to you
a line from The New York Times.
Quote, Forces that somewhat contained
his autocratic tendencies
in his first term would all be weaker.
As a result, Mr.
Trump and his advisers more extreme,
extreme policy plans
and ideas for a second
term would have a greater prospect
of becoming reality.
So what worries
you most about a second
potential Trump term?
Well,
the fact that
he probably be better at it.
Nobody thought he was going to win.
He didn't think he was going to win.
So he had no actual plan.
He had a campaign team.
He didn't have a governing team.
So the whole thing was a dumpster
fire from the beginning.
But that was actually a good thing
because a lot of stuff he wanted to do
he just didn't know how to do.
Having worked in the White House,
you spend the first week
trying to find the restrooms.
I mean, it's not an easy place
to learn how to operate.
So this guy winds up getting a bus.
You don't know how to drive the bus.
And so he spends the first four years
learning how to drive the bus.
And there were people in there
who were slowing him down,
putting up the guardrails this time.
That won't be the case.
You got four years to get ready.
He's got a team of weirdos and wackos
who thought this thing through.
And when he gets in there, he's
going to know
exactly what he wants to do.
And now he knows how to drive the bus.
If you thought he was going fast
and furious
the first time around,
you've seen nothing
on the second time around.
And it's not just about
you never have another election.
You thought that last ride was bumpy.
This is going to be insane.
And you might have any number of things
happen to you and your family
that could have been prevented
by just good orderly governing
that could happen to you,
your family, your neighborhood.
You have no idea
what you're signing up for.
You don't like Joe Biden. That's fine.
But you don't put your family
on a bus driven by a mad man
because you don't like
the other bus driver.
You know, Gloria,
we heard Trump are now accusing Biden
of being a threat to democracy.
Should Democrats be concerned
that Trump can effectively
turn the tables on Biden?
Well, Trump does this all the time, Wolf.
He accuses people of doing things
that he's accused of.
And I remember back in
2016 when he was debating Hillary Clinton
and she accused him of being a puppet
of Putin.
And he said, no, you're the puppet.
And that's what that's what this is.
I think, look, Democrats
have to counter it.
They have to counter every charge
that Donald Trump is making,
no matter how ridiculous.
And I think this will be
one of the easier ones
for them to counter
by reminding people
that he tried to overturn
a fair election.